in this video we'll talk about the
spleen
in humans the spleen is a purple colored
organ present in the left upper quadrant
of the abdomen spleen is the secondary
lymphoid organ in the body and it's the
largest secondary lymphoid organ
the spleen is a secondary lymphoid organ
spleen acts primarily as a blood filter
it removes red blood cells so it's a
graveyard for rbcs now also spleen has
immunological functions because it
houses lymphocytes such as B lymphocytes
and the monocytes
so this is a cross section of the spleen
let me Orient you to the anatomy
so first of all you can see the splenic
arteries here and the splealing vein is
here so these are the input and output
of blood into the spleen
now the central arterial supplies blood
inside the spleen
and around the central arterial there
would be several sinuses
this is the tropical which is basically
the capsule invaginating inside the
spleen the most important part of the
spleen is here
the periarterular sheath
which is in blue then the follicles
and the marginal Zone
so the marginal Zone pulse and the
follicle together are known as white
pulp
external zone of this white pulp is
known as the red pulp
in a histological slide we can quickly
appreciate that white pulp is in this
region and the red pulp is the external
region
so what is the function of red pulp red
pulp filters abnormal rbcs and platelets
it's also a zone for fetal
erythropoiesis and it sequesters
platelets so red pulp has hematological
functions whereas the white pulp has lot
of immunological functions
so in the white pulp you can see the
jump jump centers present in the B cell
follicles
then periarterular sheath which has T
cells and the marginal Zone which has
antigen presenting cells so let us look
at this in bit more details
so the periarterular sheath is the house
for several T cells so it you can
consider this is the T Cell Zone
and then the follicles has many B cells
and the marginal Zone has B cells as
well as antigen presenting cells such as
macrophages and the dendritic cells
so what happens is that in the marginal
Zone
there are specific cells like dendritic
cells there are macrophages which can
recognize blood-borne pathogens and
bacteria especially the encapsulated
bacteria and they can engulf them
eventually these antigen presenting
cells can now present this antigen to
the T helper cells present in the
periarteriola sheep in this blue region
and later on the T helper cell once
activated can now go to the follicles
and can interact with the B cells to
activate the B cells eventually B cells
would give rise to plasma cells and make
antibody against that particular
pathogen so this is the overall function
of the spleen
now spleen is kind of equivalent to the
lymph node but a bigger version of the
lymph node it's much much bigger than
the lymph node anyway
enlargement of the spleen is known as
splenomegaly and splenomegaly is caused
by many disease Associated situations
like sickles and anemias scardosis
malaria bacterial endocarditis leukemia
and many more
now splenic dysfunction could be very
bad for an organism splenic dysfunction
can occur due to a surgical removal of
spleen splenectomy or sickle cell
disease Auto spleenectomy or maybe
rupture of the spleen due to any kind of
accident so overall splenic dysfunction
can lead to problems especially with the
capsule containing bacterias
so when spilling spleen is dysfunctional
blood IGM level would go down
complement activity would also go down
it would increase the risk of
encapsulated bacterial infection
so generally the encapsulated bacteria
are cleared by the spleen one spleen is
not functional the risk of these
encapsulated bacteria such as
streptococcus pneumonia hemophilus
influency type B nissaria meningitis
there
the infection risk is increasing
so obviously a clinical focus is to
vaccinate the individual which has
undergone splenectomy or clinic
dysfunction so the vaccination against
the encapsulated organism is really
important so I hope this was informative
and brief enough so if you like this
video give it a big thumbs up you can
visit our Facebook page Instagram
or other social media links all are
provided in the description support our
Channel using super thanks you can
contribute using paytm PayPal or UPI see
you next video
foreign